so-called ocean heat waves are happening
more often lasting longer and becoming
more severe that's according to a recent
data published in scientific journals
researchers compared the phenomenon with
wildfires on land but instead of wiping
out for us they destroyed kelp sea grass
and coral reefs underwater one group of
scientists is trying to save coral reefs
by cataloging all 150,000 of them
worldwide for his Climate diary series
Mark Phillips swam along on a recent
expedition to the most famous coral reef
in the world welcome to the Great
Barrier Reef into the world's biggest
reef mapping project because if you want
to know how the reefs of the world is
doing this is how research on the
world's threatened coral reef systems
has traditionally been done
a team of marine scientists flies out
the destination this time ladyelliot
Island a speck of coral on Australia's
1400 mile long Great Barrier Reef the
team inspects the coral this particular
patch seems to be doing ok the coral
seems stable and the local wildlife
seems to be holding its own but the team
including marine biologist Emma Kennedy
knows they're only getting a close-up
view of a much bigger and not always
happy picture has any set a number of
scientists and really we can only cover
very little ground going out with our
scuba diving here over an area that
decided Japan is huge but a new tool is
being developed to provide that bigger
picture
this is ladyelliot island reef up close
this is it from space and these are
other reefs all over the world subsea
science has met outer space science we
have liftoff of the Delta bar we look
down you've got to go up a new system
has been launched where swarms of
shoebox-sized many satellites have been
deployed to orbit over the North and
South Poles and take pictures as the
Earth spins underneath that means by the
way that we see every field every tree
every reef everywhere every day we're
gonna go right in to ladyelliot
Island where you were located and that
says planet labs and Rizzoli means
because we see them every day
we can see how they're changing changing
too often in these global warming days
from healthy living organisms to dead
ones rising ocean temperatures have been
killing coral leaving a white skeleton
behind they call it bleaching nobody
knows exactly how much of it has
actually been happening but they soon
will the planet imagery is coming over
on the daily basis we finally can get a
good eye on where it's changing you're
we're not chris roelfsema is another
marine scientist who spent a career
studying reefs up close so this is
what's mapped along with partners at
Arizona State University
he's using his knowledge to develop
software to turn the satellite pictures
into a diagnosis of reef health or
sickness the point being that you'll be
able to do this on every reef in the
world that's that's the idea and that
information is being assembled for the
first time in a worldwide living coral
Atlas run by the estate of the lake
Microsoft co-founder and marine
enthusiast Paul Allen
the marine scientist and the space
scientists are pulled together by
project coordinator Lauren kickin back
my excitement comes when I share this
with the people in the field that are
actually going to be using it and
they're just amazed and that sort of
responds yeah it makes you feel pretty
good the world's coral reefs are not
important just because they're nice to
look at they're important for what they
tell us about what's happening to the
planet the turtles may not give
interviews and in the one you need but
geology professor Stuart Finn does why
is it important to pay attention to the
health of the world's reefs is it are
the reefs to coin a phrase the canary in
the coal mine that they are the canary
in the coal mine because their oceans
and heat redistribution and oceans
drives our global climate system yes
you're right
monitoring how the oceans are changing
how that affects the reefs the climate
and ultimately us will now get a little
easier it's gonna be a fantastic
resource for scientists trying to
understand what's happening
ya know much better a project this big
of course takes time it won't be done
for two and a half years and then we'll
keep on watching
it's incredible to think they could map
all those coral reefs yeah and as
beautiful as they are it's important to
remember that they're a gauge of the
world's health really and that climate
change is real yeah is there anything
Mark Phillips can't do any story can't
do I love his writing I know yeah he's
great great wait a minute able to come
up with one yeah challenge for you Mark
Phillips well done well done beautiful
piece